next time what you will see is something
that was missing from many of typical
notations of many assignments what what
is it what is the complexity of the
ray-tracing algorithm depend on well it
depends on the resolution of the bigger
image to model it takes talent it is
exponential with respect to the depth at
least this implementation is if you if
you should have to raise there is always
a branching then this is going to be
exponential so we have taken into
consideration resolution we have taken
to consideration depth but we haven't
taken taken into consideration how many
objects there are in the scene and if
you start running the same ray tracer on
a huge scene because you don't want to
see spheres you want them to do ray
tracing like real men do then what you
do is you implement a function that can
load you triangle lashes and then you
just grab a nice triangle mesh and I
seen from somewhere loading to your ray
tracer and you're very excitedly random
a tracer and you don't get anything in
your whole lifetime if you know
something with millions in it which is
not much nowadays why someone I feel
just pleased wrong that's true why does
it take a lot of does you have to do a
lot of intersection tests exactly so I
have if I have 1 million objects I have
to do 1 million intersections every
single time that's too much it's just
way too much so what we can do is that
we can do some kind of space
partitioning which means that simple
optimizations I can do for instance I
really don't care what is behind me
because I'm going to intersect something
that's in front of me so whatever is
behind me I can immediately throw this
all of those polygons out test
immediately half of it and if you use
smart tricks and KD trees smart tricks
smart data structures you can go from
linear Y linear 1 million objects 1
million intersections so that's linear
accident you can go to logarithmic
complexity which is amazing because the
logarithm after important doesn't really
increase too much and you will learn
about techniques that will make you able
to compute this intersection we like 1
million objects with about 4 or 5
intersections on the average obviously
obviously it depends on the distribution
of the triangles and all of them but on
average you can do it in 4 or 5
intersection instead of 1 million so
it's a huge huge speed up this is going
to be on the next lecture and again it
seems that I have been lying to you all
along regarding this as well because I
told you that we are measuring radians
for the remnant equation now radians I
cannot really display on my monitor what
can i display in my mirror RGB values so
there has to be some transformation that
comes from radians and converts it to
RGB in a meaningful way this process is
called tone mapping and thomas is going
to tell you all about tone mapping as
well you can do it in a number of
different ways it's have any non-trivial
and the biltong mapping method really
breathe life into your rendered images
now we haven't talked about filtering
this is a bit more sophisticated
recursive ray-tracing
you show you shoot one sample through
the midpoint of the pixels to be seen
you computed this you're done with Monte
Carlo integration we are going to have
many samples so we are going to have
metric that's called samples per pixel
and these samples will not go through
the midpoint of the pixel these are
going to go through the surface of the
pixel
like random samples over the surface of
the pixel and you're going to integrate
the radians over the whole surface now
you can do this differently because you
have many samples over the pixel surface
and
can take into consideration them into
consideration in different ways and you
can see that different filtering method
this is what we call filtering and
different filtering methods will give
you different results
and the interesting part is that you
will get anti aliasing for free if you
do filtering well because in the ray
tracer you will shoot one way through
the midpoint of the pixel your images
unless they are super high resolution
they are going to be aliased a
completely straight line is going to be
pixelated the edges are going to be
pixelated what can you do
trivial things like super sampling let's
split one pixel into four other pixels
for smaller pixels and compute the race
through all of them and average that's
the physical method that gives you
anti-aliasing by super sampling but this
is super expensive I mean you have HD
resolutions and you have to bump this up
by even four times too much there's
better solutions you can get this for
free you go to an illumination if you do
filtering right so this is what
filtering is about thomas is also going
to talk this is not one lecture this is
the next three lectures it's going to
talk about participating media what is
this about well in our simulations so
far we have taken into consideration
that rays of light only bounce off of
surfaces but in real life there is not
only surface there's volumes there's
small case many of these effects where a
ray of light can not really hit an
object but justice moan and get
scattered and if you do your simulation
in a way that it supports such a
participating medium then you can get
volume constants and that's amazing
because I just have shown you the ring
and whatever else kind of caustics it
will look at you will think of those as
as some 2d things that I see it on the
table and this diffuse material that
and diffuses this radiance back to me so
you would think that caustics and
shadows are planar they are two dean
things but they are in fact volumes so
the shadows exist not only the plane but
they have the volume because the the set
of points that are obstructed from the
light source are not on the plane they
are in 3d and you can get volumetric
caustics and volume channels will
participate in media media because there
will be a medium medium in there of
which light can scatter so therefore you
will see these boundaries you can also
get godrays beautiful phenomenon in
cricket in the nature if you compute
diversity you can also get something
like this this is an actual photograph
just to make sure that you see the
difference that the first ray is
traversing air or vacuum and the next
ones have a participating video which
can give you this affect the scattering
effect and another example of cadres
while apparently we have this do not
disturb piece of paper so there is some
rocks render and then going on in this
room you better not enter who knows what
you will see and you can get not
necessarily such pronounced effects but
the more solemn effect that you can you
can feel that there is some haze in this
image but it is not so very much now we
don't stop there because don't just
think of of smoke and atmosphere you can
just look at your own skin if you would
like to see some participating here now
this is a phenomenon we call subsurface
scattering and this means that some of
the things
you think our objects our surfaces are
in fact for use this is your skin for
instance light goes through your skin
the portion of life and we don't see it
like that because when we hit the
surface of the object we bounce to read
back and if we write a simulation that
makes us able to go inspire these
objects then we have a simulation with
subsurface scattering and we can account
for beautiful beautiful effects like
this these are some simulations so for
instance on the left side you can see
problem inaudible
there is subsurface scattering in
marbles it seems heavily exaggerated to
me or either there is a really really
strong net lighting but this is not a
surface anymore you can see the nose of
the lady light lots of the radiance
actually gets through the nose this is
one more example this is not so
pronounced and this is this is not so
exaggerated but you can see this Jade
Dragon clearly has some subsurface
scattering look at the optically thin
parts like the end of the tail you can
see that it's much lighter and this is
because some of the light is going
through it and the optically thick parts
like the body of the dragon have messed
up surface camera so you can see that
this is a bit darker beautiful
phenomenon and we can also see the link
this and okay look at this one
absolutely amazing that doesn't this
look amazing this is incredibly awesome
we can write computer programs and can
compute this reasonable amount of time
so absolutely beautiful phenomenon
that's okay this as well this is a
fractal with subsurface scattering I
mean how cool can someone get its
fractals and subsurface carries it's
like two of the best foods mix together
is
it has to be something awesome and
another example of a beautiful jade
dragon well just a bit of subsurface
scattering so that's going to be it for
today and there is going to be in the
next three lectures from us these are
all the exciting things that are going
to be discussed and then we will
complete the multicolor integration I
will tell you how I like to you exactly
and how to use mathematics to see from
these lies and I mean the right
illumination